et puis autre mobilisation toujours en
france ce matin devant le ministère de
la santé à paris le collectif la manif
pour tous a montré son désaccord avec la
future loi bioéthique qui doit être
débattu au sénat mardi prochain loi déjà
adopté à l'assemblée nationale en août
2020 non à la fabrique des bébés payés
par les français ici on achète on vend
des enfants pouvait-on lire sur les
pancartes un bébé j'ai embarqué du
symbole de l'euro a même été déployée
le projet de loi bioéthique prévoit
notamment l'ouverture de la pma à toutes
les femmes qu'elles soient célibataires
ou en couple laisse bien je vous propose
d'écouter la présidente de la manif pour
tous nous dénonçons tout l'aspect de
marchandisation humaine qu'il y a dans
le projet de loi dit bioéthique
bien sûr avec les aspects procréatif
avec la pma son père et la gp11 qui est
présente dans le texte mais aussi avec
la volonté de l'exécutif de légaliser la
création d'embryons transgénique
d'embryons chimères animal hommes et la
création de gamme est artificielle on ne
peut pas traiter n'importe comment
l'être humain on ne peut pas porter
atteinte à l'intégrité de l'être humain
même si c'est une question de de
compétition scientifique internationale
et finalement de compétition financière
et puis sur la pma son père et la gpa ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'aspects et
d'intérêts lucratif